our next guest has fought relentlessly
against medical cartels silencing
Campaign which is why he invited people
like Michelle and actual experts to join
him in Florida today and he's also
calling for a grand jury now to
investigate any and all wrongdoing in
Florida with respect to the covid-19
vaccines joining us now is Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis Governor it's
great to see you tonight
what did you learn today in hearing
again these voices many of them
suppressed or people ostracized over the
last few years
well Laura like anything I mean you you
take an m r a shot and the way to view
it is okay what are the benefits and
what are the drawbacks and it seems like
our medical establishment never wanted
to be honest with people about the
potential drawbacks and so you showed a
clip from Dr latapo down here in Florida
in the analysis that he's done with
people particularly young men who've
taken the MRNA shots we of course had
Witnesses talk about their experience
and how are we in a situation yes
Florida we ban vaccine passports almost
two years ago we banned the shot
mandates for jobs and saved a lot of
people's jobs nevertheless throughout
our country you still have hundreds of
universities in other states that are
still mandating these boosters on these
college kids when any type of cost
benefit analysis would say the benefit
from them taking the shot as you as you
alluded it to it doesn't prevent them
from getting infected or spreading it
anyways the benefit is minuscule but as
Joe latipo and other Studies have shown
you know there is a risk for doing it so
why can't our medical establishment
acknowledge that why the deception why
have they continued to do this for two
years
I want to read some of the reaction to
your move today New York Magazine's
Jonathan shait said it's been very very
obvious Iran DeSantis was courting the
anti-vaccine movement it's a case study
in conservative movements intellectual
dysfunction and similar nastiness from
Vanity Fair taking your authoritarian
Ambitions to the next level he demonizes
public health safety measures to score
political points Governor is your goal
with this round table today to demonize
public health and safety officials
well let me tell you this Laura the
authoritarians were the ones that wanted
to mandate the vaxx on people I
protected people from having that happen
and made sure Floridians could make
their own choice the authoritarians
wanted to Institute a vaccine passport
system almost like a social credit
system so that people who dissented from
this would be marginalized from society
entirely we rejected that and we banned
it so we were from the very beginning
you know helping people make their own
decisions but not using either the
coercive power of the state or allowing
big corporations to condition those
choices and so look at the end of the
day what we're looking for is to provide
truth to provide accurate data and
provide uh accurate analysis and we had
a great researcher from Denmark you know
Laura Denmark does not allow people
under 50 unless they have pre-existing
conditions to get the mnra shots because
they've analyzed it and said that the
drawbacks outweigh the benefits but
they've also looked at all cause
mortality and the researcher found that
yes in some age groups there was a
decline in coveted mortality after
taking these but there was then an
increase in other types of mortality so
why have we not seen big declines in
excess mortality since these things have
been introduced and so we have now a
panel that we've created in Florida that
is effectively going to function the way
a CDC should function and basically do
evidence-based medicine take studies
seriously that that counteract The
Narrative and be willing to ask
questions and go where the data leads
and governor on another issue today in
Washington the White House was
celebrating the president's signing of a
national National legislation to protect
both interracial marriage and
non-traditional marriages gay marriage
and the like
um there are a lot of religious
conservatives and other traditional
Americans who are concerned that this
will end up being a severe encroachment
on religious liberty and religious
conscience rights and I wonder if you
might have a reaction to those concerns
well I think they're valid concerns I
mean Laura was interracial marriage
being even debated in this country
nobody's talking about that uh they're
using the power I think of the federal
government uh in ways that will
absolutely put religious institutions in
difficult spots if you have people uh
that are so inclined to be very
aggressive against that and I don't
think that it was there was certainly no
need to do this and I do think that
those concerns were valid uh and there's
the other issue Brewing here which will
affect all the states which is this
Omnibus spending bill which is working
its way now through the Senate with
Mitch McConnell looking like he wants to
strike a deal with Chuck Schumer a lot
of House Republicans we're about to talk
to one uh not happy about this because
obviously they're taking over the house
in a few weeks meaning no leverage for
the Republicans going forward I know
you're not in in Congress anymore but
you have a lot of experience having been
a congressman
what would your reaction be if you were
still still up on Capitol Hill and you
just lost all that leverage next year
well obviously they should punt it to
the new Congress when we'll have the
majority in the house there'll be more
Republican leverage and they'll be able
to hopefully uh engineer a better
outcome than they will being in the
minority in both houses right now
why do you think the Republicans would
not want to do that Kevin McCarthy or
whoever will be speaker why do you think
Laura Laura you're looking to a guy that
uh has voted against Omnibus bills in my
sleep when I was in Congress I mean
that's just the way these guys operate I
I never fit into that and and part of
the reason I ran for governor quite
frankly is because I didn't like the way
Washington operated but um yeah you have
uh really both parties have been
addicted to these big Omnibus bills
they'll put it out it'll be thousands of
pages no one will really be able to read
it and it's basically back to Nancy
Pelosi Nancy Pelosi government pass it
to find what's in it and I think the
American people are sick of that
Governor DeSantis we really enjoy the
round table today thank you for staying
on this issue of covet accountability
it's great to see you tonight hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else